I mean Tory MPS targeted by an
anti-brexit campaign film discussing
opportunities with a fake South Korean
firm no rules being broken but awkward
nonetheless so we were we were wondering
do you have a daily rate
at the moment I do I do yes it's 10 000
Sterling
Matt Hancock's team said this covert
recording was illegal and he acted
entirely properly this senior Tori was
also targeted I was thinking something
like sixty thousand pounds
sixty thousand
oh
okay
let me know
so Graham Brady said as he is standing
down as an MP next year he was exploring
opportunities
this Minister saying no rules were
broken but that MP should work for
voters all of us will uh reflect on this
and think the the first duty of a member
of parliament is towards their
constituents and ultimately the really
important thing is isn't MP delivering
for their constituents is a member of
parliament doing everything they can to
put Public Service First this secretly
filmed footage is clearly embarrassing
for those involved but it doesn't prove
any wrongdoing because MPS only have to
make declarations when money is received
or when jobs are agreed that said the
issue of outside earnings has come into
close Focus recently with some calling
for a tightening of the rules around
second jobs
Sky's Westminster account tool shows
that since the end of 2019 Matt Hancock
has declared 33 Financial interests
that's donations earnings and Gifts
worth over half a million pounds His
Highest payment was 320 000 pounds for
his I'm a celebrity appearance followed
by 48 000 for a serialization of his
Memoir making him the MP with the
seventh highest amount of outside
earnings
so Graham Brady has 137 Financial
interests totaling just over two hundred
and ten thousand pounds His Highest
payment was 64 000 pounds from a
publishing group followed by 31 000 for
marketing and comms advice putting him
in 25th place I think no one can watch
that video and see these reports without
feeling sickened quite honestly at them
parading themselves around trying to to
get extra paid political consultancy
because that's what that is and that's
why we've been calling for an end to
Second jobs for for MPS and end to these
paid political consultancy roles the
influence of private cash in this place
is well documented so while these
Revelations won't surprise some for many
they will emphasize the need for reform
Rob palski news in Westminster